موسكو غاضبه من تسليم دول الغربيه دبابات
اليوم باردا المانيه الصنع الى كياف
الرئاسه الروسيه تباعدت بتدمير هذه
الدبابات في ساحات المعركه المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه قال ان هذه الخطه مكلفه
الاوروبيين
ووصفها بالعبديه التي لن تكون لها اي
اضافه في ساحه الحرب
من الواضح ان هذا تقدير مبالغ فيه
للامكانيات التي ستضيفها الدبابات الى
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه انها فكره
خاطئه اخرى بشكل عميقا كررنا مرارا ان هذه
الدبابات ستحترق مثل كل الدبابات الاخرى
انها باهضه الثمن وكل هذا سيسقط وسيقع على
عاتق دافع الضرائب الاوروبيه
في المحيط الاطلسي والموازنه مع هذه
التحذيرات بتت موسكو صور اختبار جديد
لجاهزيه قوتها البحريه لاستعمال صواريخ
زركون للفائقه لسرعه الصوت والقادره على
حمل رؤوس النوويه
سبق ان اعلنت انها مستعده او في طور
التفكير في تسليم دبابات اليوبارد الى
الحريفه اوكرانيا
الامريكيه الصنع الى الجبهه الاوكرانيه
بريطانيا حسنه منتصف الشهر الماضي